(swinging jazz music)
- How was that?
- Best medley of wigs yet.
That was it.
Chris, you're the best.
- You see that?
I think that lady just
threw away a brand new baby.
- This one?
- Yeah.
(sharp inhalation)
- Yep, that's a baby.
(upbeat pop music)
- At least she used
the recycling bin.
- Did you see what
that baby was wearing?
- Sure I did.
(carnival music)
Who wants watermelon?
It's one of the five
basic food groups.
- Oh no.
- Come on, have
some of my brain.
- It's a temptation
but no thank you.
- Would you like
some watermelon?
- Sure.
- Ah, mmm.
Good.
You were in my dream last night.
(carnival music)
- [Crowd] Eat it, eat it.
(crowd cheers)
- [Chris] Metal.
(heavy metal music)
- Watermelon.
Wearing a hat.
(carnival music)
(wild laughter)
- Ah, mmm.
Oh, good.
(light pop music)
- [David] How many bedrooms
do you think we need?
- [Chris] Ah, 60 at least.
(aggressive knocking)
- [Chris] Hi.
- [David] Hey, how are ya?
- This is my brother Chris.
- This is my brother David.
Yeah, were the Walsh brothers.
- And we have to let you know
that we're legally obligated
- To tell you,
- We're moving into
the neighborhood.
- Why are you
required to tell me?
- We're not required by
law to tell you about that.
- We're not legally obligated
to tell you what we did,
which is the best part.
- You gotta go and
do all that research
and stuff on your own.
- We have to let you know
that we're required by law.
- That's right, a judge
ordered it, decreed it.
- To tell you we're moving
into the neighborhood.
- [David] What?
- I think she's required
by law to listen.
- She is required
- [Walsh Brothers] You're
required by law to listen.
- Hey, we're the Walsh brothers.
- Yeah.
- This is my brother David.
- And this is Chris.
- And I'm his brother.
- And we're here to
tell you that we're
- You're here for the party?
- Party?
- Yeah, that's exactly
why we're here.
We're here for the party.
- Yeah, yeah.
Where is it?
- Out back.
- [David] Oh, nice.
(children chatting)
(cassette clicks)
(electro pop music)
- Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
(children laughing)
Hey.
Ho.
(excited children shrieking)
Hi, hi, hi, hiya, hi.
(applause)
(children shrieking)
(laughter)
- He's a unicorn.
(yells loudly)
(children screaming)
- [Children] One, two, three.
(children laughing)
(chainsaw buzzing)
(children screaming)
(wacky electro music)
♪ Birthday to you
(percussive stab)
(children screaming)
(orchestral music)
- Hi everybody.
- Thanks for watching
another video.
- We appreciate it.
- When you're done,
go back and click on the
most terrified child.
It'll lead to a secret video.